as house of pain once said jump around
jump around jump around jump up jump up
and get down they're talking about
partying I think but it may as well be
the anthem of a remarkable hopping
little rodent called the jerboa just
look at those crazy long legs the jerboa
looks like a tiny kangaroo only doesn't
have an Australian accent because it
lives in the deserts of North Africa and
Asia and the Arabian Peninsula and no
jerboa is cuter or more bizarre than
this super rare and sadly endangered
long-eared jerboa for the love of Pete
look at this magnificent thing now
the drew boa kind of looks like it has
backwards knees but in fact that long
bit is made up of super stretched out
foot bones its knees are actually up at
its torso equipped with such powerful
legs
the tiny rodent can leap up to 6 feet
and that's not just because it digs
house of pain it for just four scenes
out in the open where plenty of birds of
prey keep watch but why not stick to the
protection of a bush well the jerboa
shares a habitat with the ravenous
gerbil which in addition to being the
world's worst first pet also eats seeds
and tends to stick to shrubbery the only
escape option for the gerbil is to
pretty much just run full tilt straight
ahead but their drew boa is a master of
manoeuvrability it Jukes right or left
and can rocket itself straight up in the
air
this is confounding for birds of prey
because they have to perfectly time
their attack they only get one shot to
land on their target
if the Drobo is joking around it's that
much harder for the hunter by venturing
out into the open the jabo it takes on
some risk but avoids competing for food
with those rascally gerbils so jump
around little chabela round round jump